-Performing
"Kiss Me (I Loved You)"
from his new album, "Chloe and
the Next 20th Century,"
please welcome
Father John Misty!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ I swore I wouldn't do this ♪
♪ The wine's gone to my head ♪
♪ The ferryman's been stranded ♪
♪ Stay with me tonight instead ♪
♪ The end will not befall us ♪
♪ The sky will not descend ♪
♪ Life can be
more sweet than bitter ♪
♪ If you'll only let me in ♪
♪ Kiss me ♪
♪ Like long ago ♪
♪ I still know ♪
♪ Our dream ♪
♪ Ended like dreams do ♪
♪ But kiss me ♪
♪ I loved you ♪
♪ Oh, oh ♪
♪♪
♪ I heard everything about you ♪
♪ And maybe half
of it was true ♪
♪ Love is much less a mystery ♪
♪ Than who you give it to ♪
♪ Oh, oh ♪
♪ Kiss me ♪
♪ Like long ago ♪
♪ I'm still yours ♪
♪ Baby ♪
♪ Our dream ♪
♪ Ended like dreams do ♪
♪ But kiss me ♪
♪ Don't you miss me? ♪
♪ Kiss me ♪
♪ I loved you ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]